[Music]
as far as i know the american
african-americans right even though they
are at the lowest wrong in the
socio-economic
ladder right they're still globally
right
at something like the 30th richest
nation in the world right
so even though there's inequality which
is a problem because
the genie coefficient sure is what is
correlated with the most with violence
sure
even though there's that problem there
which is a extreme problem i don't think
that problem can be just
pinned down to capitalism because i
think almost any system or
every single system ever produced
produces a pareto distribution including
marxism so for example in the soviet
union
it's like we're all equal but we're
equal at pretty much zero and then
the government the people that are in
the government have the most wealth
right
yeah so it's not as if we can just say
capitalism a consequence of capitalism
is the inequality right
and then the oppression that goes along
with that it's not as if that can be
laid to capitalism at least not in my
eyes so what do you think would they lay
it to them i mean i i don't understand i
mean it's produced
yeah the distribution governs any
creative output so for example
ten percent of the trees in the forest
get ninety percent of the right right
five percent of the stars have ninety
five percent of the mass right so it's
any creative outbreak any time you have
a system where
there is creating right there will be
some people who are better naturally
or there will be some people who just
get lucky and it just
that just is that's almost a law of
nature so that's what i would say to
that but i want to know what you would
say you would say
one of my response is that you know you
know whether or not we accept
that there's not that pareto the pareto
pattern that you're describing
yeah yeah i'm familiar with but but uh
you know i haven't looked at in
many ages but but uh i understand what
you're saying you know
that the idea is basically that um i i
would look at it this way that
um is what you do about it and why it's
produced in the
in in different circumstances that
matter right that if we're human agents
we understand you know how it is i mean
people die people live they say well
people die okay let's just kill people i
mean that's just you know not worry
about health i mean they're not you know
i mean
ninety percent died so it's fatalistic
exactly is that exactly well that exists
let's not say
anything about it yeah it's a dire
problem exactly so i'm not sure yeah i'm
not convinced
but i'm not i don't know i don't right
no much right so that's why i'm here
sure i understand i'm not convinced that
the marxism is the answer
to solving the inequality gap i mean the
the well marxism is inequality the
problem of inequality okay marxism per
se is a form of analysis it's a
it's a logic it's it's uh you know it's
become a kind of
complex of people with shared
orientations coming out of
marx and angles and and so on right
through the whole history since the 19th
century right
um but you know socialism there's other
things that our sense try to address
of which marx tried to martian english
tried to also
confront how do we think about socialism
and so on
but that's more of the issue in terms of
how to address things right
so if if if society naturally produces
inequality which is what you're arguing
for anything produce almost anything yes
any sure that has
output produces gets more equality yeah
right yeah um the the question is um
you know we're not supposed to just
accept that no i mean
the whole difference of human agency is
and and so as if
right so i mean yes to go to some place
natural context and
some lions get more food and some don't
um
right so they don't have the capacity to
organize themselves socially we do
we have an organized society we call
civilization
whatever you know political society and
so on they don't have that they have a
sort of natural
uh ways that they connect to each other
you could even call society if you
wanted but it
it doesn't there's not a constructed
thing a complex constructive thing
that anything in any way is is sort of
reminiscent or
uh is similar to human society right
so human society has that ability so if
we
take things that come from nature and so
on and allow it to be that way
to give it opportunity to manifest right
just like disease has vectors too
so we not deal with disease and say well
yeah okay there's a flu and 15
will die automatically let's not worry
about them let them okay let's reduce
the surface population
and move on so in other words simply
because it's natural doesn't mean we
shouldn't try to tinker with it because
we can benefit everybody and then we
exactly that we can't and we can't
and there's no reason why we can't
address it right okay
because of that because you could argue
anything is natural in the 19th century
there were
huge arguments that there's natural
inequality and there is a sort of
natural inequality i mean i'm not
denying natural inequality
nor would marx have denied natural
inequality there are faster people
there are people who can calculate
better you know and so on they can see
better people would see better than me
i'm wearing glasses i mean
you don't have them maybe you have
contacts but we're naturally unequal in
that category
the world is full of that it's a
question of what you do with it right so
there's that kind of inner coordinates
inequality of outcome
which is you know you know so how is our
how society organized because you can
see much better than me
should you get a house that has heat in
winter and i shouldn't because i
couldn't see where to go and couldn't
get
there right so that would be the pareto
argument would say
no you get you you just do the thing you
just follow the natural pattern right
you don't organize society no what i was
saying is
what i was saying is the inequality
cannot be laid to capitalism cannot be
you can't just lay that at the feet of
capitalism the fact that there's an
inequality
i have responses yeah now there is
something that we can do about
inequality
right what can we do i don't actually
know but obviously we can
remedy and we must remedy it at some
point because it's just going to get too
extreme and then there's going to be
the genie coefficient is going to
collapse the whole society sure maybe
that's what marx is saying is that it
goes from slavery
to feudalism right capitalism to
communism
sorry marxism let's say socialism and
then
right question mark and then utopia
somehow but i don't know i don't know
maybe i'm a
strong man right marx and i don't know i
just don't just saying that but i would
say that
um capitalism i would understand it this
way capitalism
produces accentuates develops inequality
you know putting a pareto aside it by
definition does that because right away
you have a separation between the word i
agree i agree with that yeah so it
accentuates so it's any
what form it takes just like the nazis
did it also
you mentioned soviet you know the soviet
union and
stalin did it in his way you know
whatever i mean
yeah i mean there were efforts to undo
it
that's the thing right so you can start
from there and things could come
undermined there is a natural tendency
for things to concentrate
i i understand what you're saying but
capitalism the problem is capitalism is
particularly
powerful particular power form for that
development
okay and uh and damaging and that's
where
it comes in right so and then it does
not offer any antidote
uh to it it's not you know it it's it's
basically not interested
and even if it gives some better because
we have a lot of people who are now
making arguments about
why the
you know let's say workers are much
better off the average person
is much better off today than they were
200 years ago which no one would deny
i know marx had denied that right yeah
he recognized that yeah whatever you
know you're familiar with some of this
work uh
uh donna mcclousky someone who's you
know been writing on that you know a lot
however yeah but even so that's resting
on a
global context of incredible
exploitation and imperialism
and there are lots of people large
numbers even within let's say north
america
and even europe who are suffering
[Music]